You know what they used to do to guys like
that when they were in a place like this?
They'd be carried out on a stretcher, folks.
I'm gonna stomp all over your face with golf
spikes
because I'm gonna win this for the state of
Pennsylvania.
You cannot be civil with a political party
that wants to destroy
what you stand for, what you care about.
If politics these days seem especially ugly,
that's because they are.
Not even counting physical attacks on Senator
Rand Paul,
the shooting of Congressman Steve Scalise
and the punching and kicking that have become
routine at demonstrations
politics are more heated and divisive than
they've been in years.
And for good reason, the people who control
politics
insist that every piece of legislation, every
supreme court nomination,
every midterm election, every minor rule change
is bringing the world one step closer to the
apocalypse.
Using plastic straws, kneeling for the national
anthem, decade old tweets.
There isn't anything we do anymore
that doesn't immediately get sucked into angry
partisan arguments.
Civility won't return until more of us channel
our inner libertarians
and realize that not all parts of our lives
need to be politicized.
How do you expect people to respond
when we're told each day is the beginning
of the end of our way of life,
that the other side is not just mistaken but
pure evil-
You are either complicit in the evil, you
are either contributing to the wrong
or you are fighting against it.
And we're limited to two parties that represent
fewer and fewer of us.
The government is spending more, it's borrowing
more
and it's controlling more and more aspects
of our lives for no reason other than pure political gain.
If we are fortunate enough two win back the
House and/or the Senate.
That's when civility can start again.
If civility can't return to politics unless
your team is in charge, you're doing it wrong.
Civility is only going to return when people
stop treating politics as the only thing that matters
and we start actually shrinking the size,
scope and spending of government
and give ourselves some room to breathe.
That's especially true if we're stuck with
just two choices
who have pledged to screw the other side over.
Neither Republicans nor Democrats offer a
plan where you get to live however you want.
Which helps explain why so few of us want
to be part of either party.
And why civility won't return to politics
until politicians stop cramming themselves
into every corner of our lives.
Lock her up! Lock her up! Lock her up! Lock
her up!